mesdames et messieurs bonjour
et partager avec vous en france est ma
passion l'aéronautique et
tout ceci commence par une anecdote
troublante qui m'est arrivé quelques
années lorsque un ami me contacta étant
passionné d'aviation et habitant
toulouse il avait trouvé des pièces
d'avions dans la terre au sud de
toulouse
et il me demanda de les identifier donc
rapidement une j'ai mis des photos de
ses pièces sur un site internet
spécialisé
rapidement les réponses arrivent r non
on me dit c'est un ce sont des pièces
d'un avion anglais et d'autres réponses
suivirent on me dit c'est un avro
lancaster un bombardier anglais
quadrimoteur qui en 1944 fut abattu au
sud de toulouse
la personne avec qui j'étais en relation
me mit en contact avec une retraitée
arlette qui connaissait très bien
l'histoire de cet avion
arlette me raconta qu'elle s'était en
effet occupé d'accueillir les familles
des membres d'équipage de cet avion
anglais qui étaient morts dans le crash
et elle précisa qu'elle avait rencontré
un français qui avait 15 ans pendant la
guerre et qui avait été témoin de ce qui
s'était passé et arlette me dit cette
personne de pouvoir amener des éléments
intéressants je vais te mettre en
contact avec lui et arlette mis en
contact avec rené qui était mon voisin à
25 ans plus tôt qui habitait la maison
d'à côté
lorsque j'étais un jeune marié avec des
enfants très jeunes et rené me raconta
en effet que pendant la guerre il avait
vu des morceaux de l'avion qui avait été
pulvérisé
partout dans le quartier y compris sur
son terrain et donc je lui dis mais rené
s'il y en avait sur le terrain est ce
que je peux jeter un oeil ce que je peux
chercher donc rené médias pas de
problème et je commence à regarder dans
le jardin rené et en effet je trouve des
pièces de l'avion
c'était très troublant et l'idée m'est
venue filmer rené s'il ya des pièces sur
votre terrain là oh moi j'habitais 25
ans plus tôt on a peut-être donc rené me
dit mme écouter la personne qui a acheté
votre maison est quelqu'un de très
sympathique
je vais en parler à mon avis devrait
être d'accord revenez dans trois
semaines
trois semaines plus tard je reviens dans
ma maison une ancienne maison
là c'est une expérience très troublante
parce que une maison vous en souvenez
donc je redécouvre l'intérieur
le nouveau propriétaire charmant
m'accueille
le montrent les travaux qu'il a fait
magique dans son jardin mon ancien
jardin et je me retrouve en effet à
chercher des pièces dans mon jardin et
là je trouve cette montre cette montre
gousset magnifique et là deux
possibilités soit allé à quelqu'un du
quartier qu'il a perdu soit il était un
des membres de l'équipage de l'avion
anglais mais comment savoir
le hasard faisant bien les choses il me
met en contact à ce moment là avec une
personne qui est passionné d'horlogerie
qui démonte la montre qui me fait un
rapport d'experts et dont deux indices
concordants
le fait que ce soit une montre suisse
qui vendait la royal air force
avant la guerre et le fait que l ai subi
d'intenses chaleurs montre assez
clairement
c'était une montre d'un des membres de
l'équipage qui était sous mes pieds 25
ans plus tôt voilà cette anecdote est
pour vous montrer combien cette démarche
d'archéologie aéronautique peut être
trop blanc est interpellante est belle
aussi et nous allons rentrer maintenant
dans la démarche elle même qu'est ce que
c'est que l'aéro l'archéologie
aéronautique
ça consiste à trouver des pièces des
pièces d'avion voyez comme celle là par
exemple puis les faire parler
vous voyez sur celle ci il y à un
chiffre ce chiffre va dire des choses
ensuite on va reconstituer l'événement
qu'est ce qui s'est passé est ce que
c'était un combat est ce que c'était
pendant l'entraînement
l'avion est tombé est ce que le pilote a
survécu à sauter en parachute
est-ce qu'il est mort on va essayer de
reconstituer l'histoire puis on va
partager on va partager nos résultats
sont à trouver en publiant en écrivant
en faisant des conférences en faisant
des expositions une façon de faire
revivre des avions oublié finalement
comment varda vion on va aller sur un
site ou un avion s'est écrasé en
l'occurrence typiquement ces témoignages
humains qui va nous mettre sur la piste
c'est un paysan qui avait 15 20 ans
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale qui
se souvient qu'un avion est tombé là qui
peut nous l'indiqué on va aussi le
valider avec des archives on va plonger
dans les archives et chercher les
endroits où un avion peuvent être tombé
les photos nous parle il ya cet avion
qui brûle le voici ici on voit très bien
la trajectoire qui l'a suivi et c'est
tout l'emplacement où on va trouver des
pièces d'avions la photo aérienne est
très utile aujourd'hui un site
géoportail sur lequel vous pouvez
gratuitement regarder des photos datant
de 1946 47
car au sortir de la guerre une grande
campagne photographique a été mené on a
fait une espèce d'état des lieux de la
france pour voir comment l été et donc
de nombreuses photos en noir et blanc
sont disponibles et sur une photo
aérienne 1946 1947
vous pouvez voir le point d'impact de
l'avion ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
parce que la végétation a repoussé mais
à cette époque vous pouvez distinguer et
ça vous permet de valider avec certitude
l'emplacement où l'avion est tombé en
l'occurrence ici sur la photo de droite
et une forêt et dans la forêt il y à un
troublant c'est un endroit où il ya plus
d'arbres parce qu'un avion s'est abattue
la donc 1946 les arbres n'ont pas eu le
temps de repousser et vous êtes certains
ici que l'avion est tombé à cet endroit
là la recherche des pièces parfois dans
des endroits reculés vous pouvez les
trouver
posés par terre cela peut arriver encore
mais la plupart du temps c'est quand
même
en creusant on va chercher dans la terre
les pièces d'avion et on va les faire
parler on trouve des pièces on les
nettoie et parfois qu'on a de la chance
on les fait parler au sens étymologique
du terme
voyez ici à gauche il y est écrit on
devine landing gear train d'atterrissage
d'un avion américain à droite je tarde
turn ou nevers machine start frei pardon
c'est un avion allemand ici sens de
rotation de la pompe
nous avons un avion français leschi des
choses il voyait sur cette petite
plaquette qu'on avait trouvé au milieu
de pièces d'avions n'ont pas identifié
on devine des 520 des 520 on s'est tout
de suite que nous avons à faire un de
watine 520 un chiffre peut nous révéler
beaucoup de choses ici vous voyez on a
ce qu'on appelle un macaron
du pilote et au dos du macaron il y a
son intrigue hull le matricule c'est
l'homme et l'homme voilà sept pilotes de
cet hydravion le graal du chercheur
c'est cette petite plaque en métal qui
est sur chaque avion
chaque avion et numérotées il porte une
plaque comme ça c'est l'adn de l'avion
numéro de l'avion sa date de fabrication
il ya son modèle donc cette plaque là en
l'occurrence nous a permis d'arriver à
cette photo nous sommes certains que
cette plaque et des sur cet appareil
maintenant nous allons reconstituer
l'événement
comment on va faire pour savoir ce qui
s'est passé on va d'abord écouter les
acteurs les témoins les faire parler
et notez ce qu'ils nous disent puis
partant de ces témoignages nous allons
continuer la recherche avec l'ordinateur
internet est une source extraordinaire
d'information il ya des sur lesquels les
experts du monde entier se promènent
avec leur savoir leurs archives
il suffit de leur poser des questions on
va acheter des bouteilles à la mer sur
ses forums en dix ans connaissez vous
l'histoire de tels pilotes
pouvez vous me donner des informations
sur tel avion et façon très surprenante
il ya des gens qui vous répondent quatre
coins du monde et qui chacun vous amène
une pièce du puzzle et vont reconstituer
le puzzle est ainsi l'histoire prend
forme et vous savez ce qui s'est passé
cette discipline est mené par trois
principes qui sont des principes
fondamentaux qui sont petit à la mémoire
de le respect petit roi le partage
alors on va développer la mémoire nous
faisons ça pour la mémoire la même
naviguant ses pilotes qui ont été
oubliés et qu'on essaie quelque part de
faire revivre donc la mémoire de ces
hommes
ensuite le respect du site le site où un
avion est tombé souvent c'est un endroit
où un homme est mort donc c'est d'en
traiter comme un sanctuaire
c'est un endroit où on va aller avec
respect et dont ne dévoilera pas le
positionnement exact pour éviter que
d'autres personnes s'y rendent
le respect c'est aussi le cadre éthique
et juridique n'est pas question de faire
une recherche si on n'a pas toutes les
autorisations administratives en amont
l'autorisation du propriétaire du
terrain
l'autorisation du service archéologique
adéquat
alors ça c'est ce qu'on ne veut pas
faire vous voyez c'est l'enrichissement
personnel
malheureusement cette pièce là ces
pièces d'avion commence à avoir de la
valeur
les gens aujourd'hui achète genre de
choses et on voit malheureusement un
business un de l'argent cela s'en mêler
voyez sur leboncoin sur ebay on a des
gens qui commercialise des pièces
d'avion c'est exactement ce que nous ne
voulons pas faire ce que nous voulons
c'est le partage nous refaire revivre
des avions et des hommes qui ont été
oubliés donc on raconte leur histoire en
publiant en faisant des expositions un
détail agréable que je tiens à souligner
c'est que très sincèrement chaque fois
lorsque vous arrivez chez quelqu'un vous
êtes très bien accueilli parce que vous
fait revivre l'histoire de son terrain
de son pays de sa région et donc il est
ravi de vous ouvrir ses portes et la
plupart du temps ce sont dans des cadres
magnifiques
je dirais que peut-être la dimension la
plus gratifiante de cette discipline
c'est l'émotion s'est retrouvé des
personnes des acteurs ou des descendants
des enfants des petits enfants des
neveux qui ne savait pas ce qui s'était
produit qui n'était pas au courant de
l'accident de leur grande honte de leur
grand père et lorsqu'on va les voir on
leur explique ce qu'on a trouvé qu'on
leur raconte l'histoire qui s'est
déroulée
clairement ça leur permet de faire le
deuil de boucler la boucle et il ya une
reconnaissance très forte et une émotion
énorme qui se dégage de cette rencontre
et quelque part nous faisons nous
donnons du bonheur aux gens et je pense
que c'est ça la dimension la plus noble
et la plus belle de ces disciplines
alors j'ai terminé par une anecdote
réelle qui s'est passé en bretagne où il
ya quelques années j'ai rencontré un
monsieur âgé gens qui m'a raconté que
lorsqu'il avait 15 ans il avait vu un
avion anglais un mustang attaqué un
train allemand
voilà lyon et lui 15 ans a vu l'avion
s'écraser il arrivé en courant il a vu
l'épave il a vu le corps du pilote qui
était mort à côté
sall avait énormément marqué bien sûr il
sera plus exactement de l'endroit où
l'avion était tombé
donc il m'a emmené à cet endroit outre
on a regardé et très rapidement on a en
effet trouvé des pièces de cet avion et
en particulier nous avons trouvé un
objet très symbolique très émouvant il a
contre la montre qui s'est arrêtée
conspirent d'anglais et jean m'a donné
la date il avait appris que le pilote
était un jeune papa et l'idée est venue
de chercher le fils du pilote
l'idée c'est de se dire que c'est en
1943 le fils du pilote avait un an deux
ans y avait de fortes chances qu'ils
soient vivants aujourd'hui donc nous
avons ri des messages en angleterre et
rapidement on a retrouvé
l'identité du pilote d'escadrille et on
a cherché une phase pilote et deux ans
plus tard nous avons reçu un mail d'une
anglaise qu'on connaissait pas qui nous
est cher monsieur j'ai vu votre demande
est la personne que vous cherchez et mon
père il est à oxford il est très
intéressé par vos recherches
voilà ses coordonnées vous pouvez
rentrer en contact avec lui c'est ce que
nous avons fait et le fils du pilote
d'abord nous a envoyé une photo de son
père
et donc on a pu voir à quoi ressemblait
le pilote et le fils du pilote très
rapidement nous a dit je veux venir vous
rencontrer
où est jean organisé mois une rencontre
donc c'est ce que nous avons fait et il
est arrivé vous voyez il est à gauche
avec son pull bleu mais elle est arrivée
il n'était pas seul il y avait trois
voitures ils étaient treize personnes
c'était toute sa famille est devenu un
pèlerinage familial et donc gens nous a
emmenés à l'endroit où il avait vu le
père de ce monsieur mourir et nous avons
tous été à cet endroit là et clim c'est
son nom le fils de pilote clim expliqué
à ses petits enfants ce qui c'était
passé qui était son père un moment très
très fort juste après nous avons été à
la mairie du village d'à côté où nous
étions attendus
madame le maire était là le conseil
municipal les anciens combattants et
madame le maire avait fait installer une
plaque à la mémoire de ce pilote sur le
monument aux morts et c'est le fils du
pilote lui-même qu'il a des bons
enfin je voudrais terminer sur cette
photo parce qu'elle est très symbolique
à mes yeux
émouvante voilà à gauche vous avez le
fils du pilote
à droite son propre fils et au milieu le
pilote vous voyez le père et le
grand-père il petit fils et la
ressemblance est frappante et il me
semble que cette image est belle parce
que elle montre combien le lien humain
est fort et beau et partant d'une pièce
d'avion
grâce à la technologie moderne ont
réussi à réunir des générations à
reconstruire l'histoire et à faire
revivre des navigants des pilotes qui
ont été oubliés